[Musique]
bienvenue c'est le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le président de la
république emmanuel battre on s'est
adressé hier aux français pour annoncé
un allègement du confinement dès samedi
prochain avec la réouverture des
magasins et des lieux de culte
les musées les théâtres les cinémas
devront attendre le déconfinement
générale prévue mi-décembre enfin pas si
général que ça puisque le couvre-feu
sera maintenu de 21h à 7h du matin sauf
les soirs du 24 décembre et du 31
décembre
quant au restaurant ils devront attendre
le 20 janvier
aucune date n'a été donnée en revanche
pour les bars ni pour les boîtes de nuit
plutôt qu'organiser un débat sur le
sujet nous avons choisi de donner la
parole à franck lepage et à ses
collègues du collectif l'ardeur connus
pour leurs fameuses conférences
gesticulées très différente de la
conférence ea mobile qui a donné hier le
président de la république
ils sont trois je vous les présente tout
de suite premier c'est franck lepage
bonjour franck vous êtes une vedette de
la contre-culture militant de
l'éducation populaire vous êtes membre
du collectif l'ardeur vos prochaines
conférences gesticulées sont prévues à
brest les 18 et 19 janvier
alors première question c'est quoi pour
vous l'éducation populaire et quel est
votre domaine de prédilection c'est de
l'éducation politique c'est de
comprendre le système comprend le
capitalisme mais domaine de prédilection
sur la culture les manipulations du
langage à côté de vous enfin à côté de
vous virtuellement il y à katia langues
bonjour katia vous avez été enseignante
pendant dix ans en maison familiale
rurale êtes aujourd'hui formatrice
d'enseignants vous accompagner des
jeunes déscolarisés et vous êtes
éducatrice populaire membre du collectif
l'ardeur vous former à la conférence
gesticulée vous animer des ateliers
alors c'est quoi pour vous l'éducation
populaire et quels sont vos domaines de
prédilection
et ben j'aime bien cette petite phrase
de paulo freire et qui dit personne
n'est dupe personne personne celle du
xxe les hommes et les femmes c'est duke
par l'intermédiaire du monde pourquoi ça
c'est pas mal et moi je suis plutôt sur
la question de l'école des pédagogies la
question de la formation professionnelle
aussi alors l'image est un peu saccadée
mes leçons fonctionne j'espère qu'il en
sera ainsi jusqu'à la fin de l'émission
le troisième c'est philippe merlant vous
avez été journaliste pendant 40 ans à
radio france à la vie à l'équipe à
libération à autrement et même à
l'expansion vous êtes co auteur avec luc
chatel de médias la faillite d'un
contre-pouvoir un très bon livre paru
chez fayard
vous avez rejoint le collectif l'ardeur
au début de cette année c'est quoi pour
vous l'éducation populaire c'est quoi
votre domaine de prédilection dans ce
domaine j'allais dire que je me retrouve
très bien dans la définition que katia
de nez fait à partir de paulo freire et
donc j'allais dire c'est une une
éducation qui est égalitaire voilà et
qui s'intéresse aux rapports de
domination générale rapports de
domination de classe de genre de race et
qui essayent de les déconstruire avec
les gens du peuple
alors commençons bas avec la tri média
la conférence de
des manuels macron hier soir vous l'avez
regardé franck lepage
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un peu
d'éducation populaire sur ce sursaut sur
cette conférence
ah oui je les regardais j'ai regardé
notre petit air dogana nous c'est de
oui-oui mais mais mais c'est normal
c'est je je je je jure un coup je te
confie d'un coup je les confie depuis je
vais voir comment je des conflits nés
puis peut-être jeudi confinerait pas les
piscines et puis pour les stations de
ski
on verra après etc enfin c'était
complètement hallucinant avec eux avec
eux l'idée de faire il a même parlé de
mettre son masque à la maison à
l'intérieur de l'intérieur du couple et
de la famille il a parlé d'isolement
contraignant bref cette mesure qui est
une mesure historique dans l'histoire de
l'humanité enfin le confinement enfin le
fait de boucler une population entière
je trouve qu ils en rient l'ennui avec
une légèreté co fondante 1 et en même
temps il est en cela représentatif d'un
nouveau capitalisme qui est tout
simplement on va appeler ça un
capitalisme autoritaire qui est une
nouvelle phase du capitalisme dont la
chine qu'elle premier capitalisme
mondial aujourd'hui a montré le chemin
je ne sais pas si vous vous rappelez au
début de l'année dernière on découvre
stupéfait que la chine peut boucler une
population alors les commentaires ils
vont bon train sur le thème ross et
communiste quand même c'est dingue ce
qu'ils font on découvre la
reconnaissance faciale enfin toutes ces
belles choses
un mois plus tard on est confiné on est
confiné pour deux mois
donc ça c'est ce que c'est ce qu'alain
badiou après l'appel du fascisme
démocratique en disant je j'entends bien
qu'il ya un paradoxe en terre mais en
même temps il est tout à fait exact ce
terme c'est une forme de capitalisme
autoritaire
la question qui sait qu'il se pose c'est
est-ce que ce les raisons de ce
confinement sont bien celles qu'on nous
dit
est ce que ce sont des raisons
sanitaires et si c'est des raisons
sanitaires
est ce que le virus la dangerosité de ce
virus là est à la hauteur de mesures qui
sont celles que auquel on est en train
de d'assister avec une mise à plat de
l'économie réelle avec des gens qui se
suicident avec des des cancers du sein
chez les femmes qui doivent attendre
sept mois un dépistage fin jeu avec des
catastrophes humble
le résultat du confinement est
probablement plus graves que le commis
lui-même
donc la question et après je n'en
resterai là pour l'introduction à la
question demeure posée c'est ok ce virus
est un virus dangereux
personne ne songe à le nier ou jeu pas
spécialement envie de l'attraper mais
est-ce que sa dangerosité est en rapport
est-ce qu'il nécessitait un confinement
si moi je veux bien comme confine si
j'ai une centrale nucléaire qui peut
être à côté de la maison aussi la peste
la peste noire du moyen âge arrive chez
moi et là ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que c'est pas la peine d'être
complotistes j'imagine qu'on reviendra
sur les questions du complotisme il
suffit de regarder les chiffres du
gouvernement les chiffres officiels
produit par le gouvernement lui-même
ces chiffres il ya deux choses à
regarder c'est la létalité est la
mortalité
la létalité de ce virus c'est le nombre
de personnes qui meurent ans après
l'avoir attrapé ça c'est la létalité la
mortalité c'est le nombre de personnes
qui meurent rapporté à la population
générale
les chiffres sont publics ils sont
extrêmement simples
la létalité de ce virus c'est que 99 5 %
des gens guérissent
c'est à dire s'en sortent sans aucun
problème et la mortalité
lassé 99,9 99.95 c'est-à-dire s'est
massivement tout le monde s'en sort sauf
effectivement les fameux 0,0 et quelques
et donc la question c'est que
probablement que la raison du
confinement n'est pas une raison
sanitaire
et si on met ça en rapport avec le fait
que c'est pas seulement en france que ça
se passe parce qu'on pourrait dire ça
c'est macron il est fou un bois de pin
toi ça se passe mondialement c'est
quasiment le monde entier en tout cas
les pays riches qui dès qu'on finit donc
le fait de mettre ces deux choses
ensemble cette année à un confinement
dont la raison n'est probablement pas
sanitaire parce que ce virus est pas
assez km est dangereux et le fait que ça
se passe mondialement
ça nous permet d'essayer de raisonner en
termes de système les deux sens du
pardon de vous interrompre fente lepage
mais on pourrait tout aussi bien dire
que les deux chiffres que vous avez
donné son simba enfin s'il ya eu si peu
de morts c'est justement parce qu on a
confiné
si on n'avait pas confiné si on avait
laissé faire comme au temps de la grippe
de hong kong
il y aurait pas eu trente ou quarante
mille morts en france il y en aurait
peut-être eu trois cent mille quatre
cent mille voire plus si vous rappelle
que les populations fragiles en france
et plus de 20 millions de gens donc
c'est plus de 20 millions de gens qui
pourraient qui risquerait de mourir si l
attraper le corps et navires us pas
forcément puisqu'il y en a beaucoup qui
guérissent
heureusement mais elle aurait pu en
mourir voilà on pourrait dire que c'est
grâce au confit manquons encore de séné
si bien tiré c'est l'argument que sortir
un gouvernement c'est évident on saura
jamais la plupart des médecins un peu
sérieux ont l'air de dire que on peut
absolument pas n'y a pas d'étude qui
permettent de dire que le confinement
nini le masque d'ailleurs en revue le
moindre effet donc on peut pas répondre
à cette question on peut effectif c'est
effectivement l'argument qui va nous
être posée c'est de dire c'est grâce au
confinement qu'il ya eu finalement pas
tellement de morts voilà oui et c'est
grâce au confinement que les courbes de
se sont aplaties comme on dit et que là
encore une fois encore dans ce second
confinement jeudi second parce que
j'espère qu'il y en aura pas de
troisième pendant ce second confinement
les courbes de nouveau se sont aplaties
grâce au confinement
enfin bon on est brimé ça donc on va
pas épiloguer sur le vous l'avez dit on
ne saura jamais si on n'avait pas
confiné peut-être qu'on a confiné parce
qu on paniquait c'est possible si on
n'avait pas confiné on ne saura jamais
ce qui se serait passé
d'accord ce qui est très surprenant
la rapidité avec laquelle tout le monde
s'est mis à confiner alors que c'est une
décision d'une d'une ampleur d'une
gravité absolument inouïe enfin deux
mois bouclé avec des avec la la police
qui vous colle des amendes qui
équipaient enfin c'est c'est d'une
violence absolument incroyable je
rappelle que quand on confine dans les
côtes d'armor il ya un cas ok et sur six
cent mille habitants enfin je veux dire
donc donc nous on pense qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas mais en même temps on
n'est pas médecin
on n'est pas médecin et donc il vaut
mieux ne pas rentrer dans ce débat
en réalité l'éducation de huy basique je
crois que ce deuxième confinement nous
montrent aussi une autre étape
ou alors il ya le premier confinement
bon effectivement on sait pas on n'est
pas médecin c'est difficile d'évaluer
tout ça mais ce deuxième confinement
quant à un moment donné j'ai prêcher
pour ma paroisse évidemment parce que
c'est ce que je connais tout à coup on
se met à imposer aux enfants dès 6 ans
par exemple ou port du masque ce que
absolument tous les parents tous les
enseignants et qui semble qu'est ce qui
peut justifier ça on obligé de se poser
la question de qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière d'autres que la protection des
malades de la protection des gens la
protection sanitaire
on est obligé de se poser cette question
là puisque de toute façon on en voit
quand même les enfants à l'école qu'on
sait qu'ils sont pas porteurs pas on
n'est pas sûr qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient transmetteur qu'ils sont un
malade que ceux-ci que cela donc
qu'est-ce qui va justifier ce à un
moment on peut dit mme peut-être que le
premier confinement a permis ceci que
une autre vague là on les met ensemble
on leur fait porter des masques mais
alors des masses poitou le plan après ce
qu'il ya quand même quand ils font du
sport et à la cantine ya et c'est pas
tout le monde tous m'ont saisi à un
moment donné que c'est aberrant cela et
qu'en plus ça a des conséquences
dramatiques que les psychologues sont
déjà en train de
de faire émerger et qui pose problème
donc à ce moment là on se dit ok mais
pourquoi ils font ça on est obligées
passé sur une analyse de systèmes et
comprendre ce qui se passe au delà de ça
on peut pas rester juste lui dire
peut-être ça sert on est obligé d'aller
au delà et vous ferez parlant ouais je
dirais moi dans mon domaine qui est un
petit peu celui de regarder les chiffres
effectivement les chiffres disent quand
même des choses étonnantes
si je prends une comparaison elle et
brooke aux pneus mot pâtit obstructive
en 2016
il ya 250 millions de personnes
atteintes de ça et il y a
environ deux millions de morts donc
beaucoup beaucoup plus j'allais dire que
la situation actuelle du coc vide
donc si on compare on est bien obligé de
se poser la question qu'est ce qui s'est
passé là pour qu'on prenne des mesures
assez radicale avec comme l'a dit franck
0,5 pour cent de létalité enfin de
personnes atteintes qui sont il ya des
gens qui commencent à dire mais imaginez
que demain est un virus du même type
mais avec une létalité beaucoup plus
forte
qu'est ce qu'on fera enfin elle veut
dire la marche pour aller au delà elle
est quand même
donc effectivement je pense que c'est
important de se dire il ya peut-être
d'autres raisons que raisons sanitaires
qui ont poussé à la mise en place de ce
confinement
il ya des raisons économiques sociales
politiques et c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire quand on fait une analyse
systémique
quand on fait une analyse systémique on
essaye aussi de sortir du simple
culpabilise de la simple culpabilisation
individuel 1 c'est à dire que on n'a pas
arrêté de nous répéter ça dépend de vous
mêmes dans le discours de mâcon hier il
y avait ce côté
bon attention on ouvre un peu les vannes
mais c'est à vous de faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas la troisième vague et
le troisième confinement et on est déjà
prévenu est d'ailleurs là-dessus
j'allais dire un certain nombre de
médias se sont faits la majorité se sont
faits un peu les relais de cette
culpabilisation personnels qui ont
peut-être m puisque j'avais préparé
quelques unis à l'alsace et les
dernières nouvelles d'alsace
à un moment donné j'ai passé vous avez
les moyens voilà corps divine navires us
gare au relâchement sur aix terme aux
carreaux relativement voilà le
relâchement
voilà donc tous viennent notre
responsabilité individuelle
les raisons sociales effectivement la
question de goût en et l'hôpital
aujourd'hui par exemple il apparaît
évident aujourd'hui que si des telles
mesures ont été prises il y avait aussi
la question du faible nombre de places
d'hospitalisation et notamment en
réanimation mais non c'est ça renvoie
toujours aux comportements individuels
des gens et s'était à nouveau sous
entendu hier dans le discours
des manuels macro mais je crois qu'on a
tous bien compris et à la limite
d'ailleurs le gouvernement ne s'en est
jamais caché le noeud de toute cette
crise c'est effectivement la peur que
les hôpitaux soient submergés par les
malades du que vides et aussi parce
qu'ils souffraient d'une autre
pathologie
et ce qui s'est passé pendant le premier
confinement c'est que il y avait
tellement de malades du coït dans les
lits de réanimation que plus personne
d'autre ne pouvait accéder et que ça a
sans doute causé et des morts et des
problèmes considérables ce qu'on a voulu
éviter pendant ce deuxième confinement
je suis toujours étonné quand on cherche
la raison quelle est la raison du
confinement quelle est la raison
parfois les raisons sont tout bête c'est
celle ci probablement il ya la panique
aussi l mimétisme parfois on fait ce que
fait le voisin parce que si on fait pas
comme le voisin
les gens vont vous le reprocher il
suffit qu'ils aient plus de morts en
france pour qu'on en veuille au
gouvernement par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé dans le pays d'à côté est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il ya tout ça
aussi et c'est au fond de tout cela que
se justifie le président de la
république quand il prend des décisions
et qu'il nous tient si souvent or au
courant des décisions qu'il prend en
quelques pages
mais justement l'éducation populaire une
démarche d'éducation populaire c'est de
dire on va pas rentrer là dedans
la question n'est pas de savoir si macro
et méchant qui dit la réalité est ce que
raul tu as raison à ce qu'il a tort
julien on assiste à ça depuis depuis un
an quasiment le problème c'est de
prendre sept points du recul et analyser
on l'a dit tout à l'heure d'analyser 6
en termes de système en termes de
système il se passe quoi est ce parce
que le capitalisme est un système de de
surproduction de marchandises et qu' il
arrive complètement à saturation et il
doit trouver des nouveaux marchés et ça
fait une bonne vingtaine d'années
si on se réfère aux textes des rapports
par exemple de l' ocde qui est un think
tank ultralibéral qu'on continue à nous
faire passer pour des experts sur sur
les ondes
ça faisait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qu'on nous dit que les deux gros marchés
sur lesquels il faut mettre la main et
faire de l'argent c'est la santé et
c'est l'éducation
le projet de l'union européenne c'est ça
le prochain le l'union européenne qu'on
nous a vendu comme étant l'europe ce qui
est une quête une arnaque
l'union européenne c'est la
privatisation de la totalité des
services publics qu'on avait mis en
place péniblement jusqu'à là il s'agit
de les privatiser parce que c'est il ya
plus que là que le capitalisme continue
à générer du profit et c'est à ça qu'on
assiste la saturation des lits
d'hôpitaux ça me fait doucement rigoler
cent mille lits détruit entre 1995 et
2000 16 cents mille lits c'est-à-dire
20% du parc ont été détruits d'accord
ont été supprimés un tiers des
maternités a été supprimée les salaires
on est on est on est au 28e rang sur 32
pour le salaire des soignants et des
infirmiers on est quasiment les derniers
de la classe
on est passé en termes de qualité de
soins de la première à la 14e place
d'accords donc tout ça ça c'est un
système un système qui consiste à
fabriquer de la marchandise et du profit
avec des choses qui jusque là échappé à
la marchandise et si vous regardez
comment comment ça se passe on construit
des maternités ont construit des
hôpitaux jusque 1981 où la droite arrive
au pouvoir avec françois mitterrand et à
partir de ce moment là vous n'avez plus
que des destructions et ça commence ça
commence avec la retraite c'est
bérégovoy qui commence qui commence à
attaquer rocard va suivre derrière etc
et on se met à détruire des hôpitaux on
se met à fermer des maternités
il se passe quoi à ce moment là est donc
arrivé là comprendre ça est arrivé à
comprendre comment nous sommes devenus
des objets de profits et comment le
marché de la santé et le marché éducatif
c'est à un véritable pactole
sauf que pour arriver à l'imposer il
faut générer ce qui est en train de se
passer ça il faut une raison supérieure
qui fait que les gens vont axe
pts et de faire de l'éducation à
distance de faire de la médecine à
distance
cette raison supérieure c'est un corps
en un virus il était de bonne foi entre
guillemets eh ben ils utiliseraient
cette expérience du confinement pour
dire ok ça y est on réinvestit
réellement dans la santé ont réinvesti
dans les établissements scolaires on
imagine que peut-elle ça doit être à
nouveau fait il nous faut plus de salles
de classe il faut diviser le nombre
d'enfants par classe ils formaient une
des lits dans les hôpitaux etc etc
or on voit bien que le confinement leur
sert au contraire à accélérer encore
plus ce qui s'est mis en place sur les
dernières années dans vienne nous parler
franc bien expliqué donc on et ses
portes ouvertes quoi ces portes ouvertes
au libéralisme on y va on y va tout ce
qui était dans les cartons on balance
tous en même temps et c'est parti c'est
henri bois on s'arrête puis même du
capitalisme une accumulation limitée des
richesses on s'attrape mais je veux pas
vous qu'il est rare et je veux pas vous
contrarier systématiquement mais mais
mais oui le libéralisme dans le fait
d'entraver le commerce pour empêcher les
commerçants de vendre ce qu'ils ont à
londres de m la société entière sous
perfusion étatique de verser des
allocations chômage comme on n'en a
jamais versé dans l'histoire de soutenir
absolument tout le monde 200 dt par
milliards pour pouvoir soutenir toutes
les sociétés
oui oui le libéralisme la devise est un
vecteur une vaste entreprise étatique
non pas du tout pas du tout c'est c'est
christine lagarde qui est qui a parlé du
grand reset c'est pas des complotistes
c'est christine lagarde
d'accord c'est l'expression que le
patronat décidé à davos d'utiliser le
grand reset
ok c'est à dire on va mettre toute
l'économie par terre on va repartir sur
des bases différentes
je veux dire et donc là la destruction
de tout là de toutes les les petits
commerces au profit des grands commerces
la destruction de l'artisanat ça fait
maintenant une quinzaine d'années avec
la loyère géo avec tous ces machins là
une disparition la disparition des
petites exploitations agricoles je veux
dire tout ça procède absolument du même
système qui est un système de
concentration du capital et
d'élimination des petits dés des niveaux
intermédiaires
alors effectivement vu vu de l'extérieur
on pourrait se dire c'est bizarre quand
même
le libéralisme il fait il met l'économie
en crise mais il met pas du tout
l'économie en crise l'économie se porte
très bien ne s'est jamais aussi bien
portée je veux dire ce qui est en train
de disparaître c'est l'économie réelle
et ce sont des systèmes de concentration
vous avez vu le gag avec les libraires
et avec avec amazon
c'est tellement évident c'est très
simple et on vous avez mais on n'avait
pas besoin du canda virus pour ça les
bistrots en france on leur nombre a dû
être divisée par quatre ou cinq depuis
que je suis née les librairies c'est la
même chose le petit commerce disparaît
au profit des grandes surfaces surtout
en france où on a fait le choix
d'attribuer des mètres carrés de grandes
surfaces
au delà de ce qu'ont fait les pays
voisins donc on n'avait pas besoin
d'accords and have used c'est la meute
il suffit de laisser ça va continuer
comme ça et de toute façon il y aura
plus de librairies plus de petites
cabanes et plus de bistrot non parce que
les capitalistes sont en concurrence les
uns avec les autres et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut utiliser ce terme au pluriel
je suis je pourrais je paraphrase emma
ou que 1000 capitalisme s'épanouissent
il faut comprendre que les classes
dominantes elles sont simultanément en
coopération et en rivalité elles sont en
coopération en tant que classe dominante
ils ont les mêmes intérêts dans le monde
entier et ils sont en rivalité en
concurrence entre des blocs l'union
européenne c'est un bloc de concurrence
qui essaye de tenir la dragée haute à la
chine aux états unis ça ans s est donc
ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
maintenir la concurrence ça suppose
constamment constamment de courir
derrière les autres et de courir
derrière les autres capitalisme et c'est
ça qui est en train de se passer
comment dire c'est pour ça que les gens
qui parlent de gouvernement mondial pour
une erreur il n'y a pas de gouvernement
mondial mais il ya une gouvernance
mondiale et la gouvernance c'est le
contraire du gouvernement si vous voyez
comment instantanément en très peu de
temps tous les pays ont réagi de la même
manière confinement blacklight plaques
etc
la simultanéité et la rapidité de cette
réponse nous permet de dire qu'il ya une
gouvernance mondiale la gouvernance
c'est très simple c'est d'empêcher les
gouvernements de gouverner c'est à dire
c'est de laisser complètement libre
cours aux multinationales
y'a pas d'autres définitions de la
gouvernance les états se mettent
actuellement au service des
multinationales et ça c'est pas du
complotisme c'est c'est cette une
une modification substantielle de
l'économie qui fait que vous avez vu le
nombre de licenciements depuis le coc
vide
je veux dire il se régale là c'est open
bar je veux dire ils licencient à tour
de bras jeunes et ils sont en train de
virer de dégraisser de de faire ce
qu'ils n'auraient pas pu faire s'il n'y
avait pas eu l'argument du duc o vite
s'arrêter quand même plus compliqué à
faire
donc moi je pense qu'ils ont besoin de
ça je pars en boucle sur le le
complotisme puisque vous avez employé le
mot et que j'imagine que un certain
nombre en vous écoutant le mot qui qui
leur viennent à l'esprit
philippe vous avez travaillé là dessus
sur le complotisme qu est ce qu on en
parle beaucoup et la rx amant encore
plus depuis depuis quelques semaines
alors déjà le terme est un peu facile de
complotisme parce que si on revient la
définition de complot le dictionnaire de
la langue française dit c'est un projet
collectif secret voilà et déjà vous
envie de dire il ya des vrais projets
collectifs secret et puis on a des
imaginaires donc il ya deux problèmes
avec les complots ce le premier c'est
d'en voir partout mais le deuxième c'est
d'en voir nulle part donc par exemple
s'établissent théoriquement maintenant
que le coup d'état qui a renversé le
gouvernement allende au chili en 1971
était fomenté par la cia
donc la question c'est cette parenthèse
qu'on peut penser qu'avec un caillou
faux complots et donc l'accusation de
complotisme elle est un peu facile et
donc le premier objectif à mon avis de
cette expression c'est de mettre du côté
du complotisme tout discours qui
questionne la vérité officielle et je
trouve qu'on en a vu un exemple les
derniers temps il ya eu beaucoup de
choses qui ont été écrites à propos du
film
hold up voilà mais dans les réactions
que ça suscité par exemple je me
rappelle france info la présenter ce
film comme dénonçant les prétendus
mensonges du gouvernement
autrement dit le fait d'utiliser ce
documentaire ça revient à remettre en
selle le fait que y aurait une vérité
officielle qui est vrai voilà presque on
parle de prétendus mensonge alors que
maintenant je pense que c'est à peu près
acquis par exemple sur la question des
masses qui a eu beaucoup de mensonges
donc c'est un espèce d'effet miroir on
utilise le complotisme au fait pour
remettre en selle et revaloriser les
discours officiels ont fait un excellent
premier rusal theron fils tu me priver
les complotistes vont croire que c'est
parce qu'on parle du complotisme mais
non on fait toujours une pause à ce
moment là et je vous donnerai la parole
juste après
[Musique]
c'est un élément essentiel au bon
fonctionnement de notre économie et
l'investissement étranger si on arrive à
être aussi attractif c'est bien qu'on
donne des compensations aux entreprises
étrangères pour venir on n'attire pas
les mouches à miel qu'est ce que c'est
que la tire et va la tirer c'est lui
donner des franchises d'un gros lui
donner un certain nombre de garanties
d'après toutes les enquêtes qualitatives
en fait c'est pas tellement la fiscalité
qui fait le petit plus c'est le petit
cerise sur le gâteau de certains c'est
essentiellement les services publics la
main d'oeuvre qualifiée
le fait que la france est au centre de
l'union européenne qui est une énorme
zone est ce que la crise a dû
coronavirus est en train de remettre
tous les compteurs à zéro
c'est en train de remettre tous les
compteurs à zéro et particulièrement
enfants je ne suis pas sûr que la mariée
soit si belle que ça
à la sortie du colis
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ce sera inscrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qu'ils prétendent et
homme d'état
[Musique]
on reprend cette émission avec franck
lepage avec katia langues et philippe
merlant trois militants de l'éducation
populaire et du membre du collectif
l'ardeur philippe merlant la parole
était à vous on était sur le complotisme
l'accusation de complotisme qui vient et
revient en permanence mais on pourrait
presque dire de tous les côtés puisque
les complotistes accuse des antilles
complotistes d'être complotistes paix et
vice versa un oui c'est fou on parle
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
complotiste pendant cette vague là alors
c'est même qu' on peut peut-être montré
une une celle de la dépêche qui titrait
sur le virus du complotisme il ya
beaucoup de médias conti trait là dessus
qu'on dit ya deux virus en fait il ya
celui du co vide mais un virus parallèle
qui circule est celui du complotisme
alors moi ce qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est
à quel point il y en a qui peuvent être
certain de donner des brevets de
complotisme à telle ou telle théorie et
c'est alors quelques fois c'est très
difficile alors par exemple dans ce
numéro de la dépêche
à l'intérieur il présentait à l'eau de
théories complotistes il y en avait 2
par exemple le premier c'était dont il
rigolait doucement c'était que agnès
buzyn était au courant des choses dès
janvier voilà donc ça apparaissait comme
complotistes de dire ça on sait depuis
que la demie elle-même orphelins la
deuxième qui était dire il ya des folles
rumeurs autour du laboratoire p4 de one
voilà comme si c'était du délire de
penser qu'il a vu plus jouer un rôle ben
à nouveau c'est une hypothèse qui fait
partie des hypothèses plausibles calabre
atteint ce soit infecté et du coup
contaminé enfin voilà donc faudrait très
très prudent je trouve par rapport à ça
et essayer au lieu de discerner des
brevets de complotisme ceci cela je
crois qu'à une autre fonction aussi du
complot à l'utilisation du complot tisba
c'est d'éteindre la liberté d'expression
puisque finalement on se dit oulala
c'est dangereux
le bas peuple est incapable de faire le
tri entre les vrais et les faux complots
donc il vaut mieux que nous ce qu'on
juge défectueuse et bas soit interdite
de diffusion
et si ce qui s'est passé là à propos du
film hold up on pense absolument pas que
peut-être
ben c'est intéressant qui continuent à
être diffusés éventuellement pour le
critiquer pour voir ce qui est mais
voilà mais il ya un phénomène
d'interdiction est donc de plus en plus
on voit cet usage du complotisme pour
interdire tout autre discours que la
vérité officielle
c'est comme si c'est là et si vous
sortez du discours officiel
vous êtes facilement étiqueté de
complotiste au lycée de chasse
d'internet il ya un peu de rémusat
j'aime la ville est viré est ce parce
que il n'est pas interdit le film il a
été viré des plateformes fassi millions
de gens l'avaient déjà été virés des
plateformes absolue ben oui mais je
considère que c'est oui c'est pas
interdit mais c'est pas une censure
d'état vous avez raison mais il a été
viré des plateformes et n'est plus
visible aujourd'hui
je rajouterais un tout petit truc sur le
le lusage du complotisme en fait parce
qu'il ya des complots des contres
complot il ya des vérités des démentis
etc
et je pense qu'au bout d'un moment ça
génère un sentiment de confusion
extrêmement fort et l'autre jour j'avais
un texte d'un philosophe mattia girel
qui disait que la confusion c'était
quelque chose qui servait bien les
intérêts des puissants des dominants
parce que quand on est dans la confusion
on ne sait plus avec qui on est contre
qui ose bas quelle alternative on est on
peut proposer et donc je pense que toute
cette séquence elle est marquée par
beaucoup de confusion y compris de la
part des experts en complotistes qui a
maintenant des experts en complotisme le
jour il ya deux ans où il ya eu la
première enquête sur ce que les français
pensent et des théories complotistes
comme on dit eh ben on en avait proposé
une dizaine de théories complotistes et
parmi celles ci il y avait aussi bien la
terrre plainte que la cia a joué un rôle
dans l'assassinât de john fitzgerald
kennedy orange ça dans le même sac dont
gardée d'orange sud en mer jaune des
participants avaient la mine de plus
c'était est-ce que vous pensez que dieu
a créé le
donc je crois qu'elle était dedans et si
vous étiez croyant vous étiez bien oui
effectivement mais donc on voit à quel
point tout ça suscite beaucoup de
confusion complotistes donné les sens
finalement parce que en tant que femme
je pense que mes hommes sur
l'intégralité de la planète a service et
les femmes à leurs propres privilèges
donc vous imaginez bien que je suis pour
petit naissance désolé mais je crois
aussi que je je crois aussi que le
complotisme c'est aussi une manière de
mépriser le peuple de mépriser les gens
de mépriser leur capacité à se poser des
questions à penser par eux-mêmes
je trouve que c'est très bien aussi avec
ce qui se passe autour d'eux autour de
ce documentaire que j'ai même pas vu un
d'ailleurs j'ai pas eu le temps de le
voir hold up mais peu importe cette
espèce de mépris dont les gens vont pas
comprendre les gens les gens vont ait
d'abord dans cette confusion alors cette
config et on allait quand même entretenu
par les médias mainstream aussi
puisqu'on a des contrevérités en
permanence et ça bouge très vite et
beaucoup mais je trouve qu'il ya
vraiment c'est de cet écrasement des
gens on va leur dire mais ils vont pas
comprendre ni vont pas comprendre et
donc s'ils sortent du discours officiels
dominant celui qu'il faut qu'on puisse
rendre qu'on puisse avaler une sans se
poser de questions si on les fait sortir
de ça olalala là ils vont vraiment dire
n'importe quoi et ça va prendre des
proportions qu'on va plus pouvoir gérer
c'est du mépris de classe et c'est assez
insupportable propre page
rien à ajouter ce que tu veux oui parce
que c'est vraiment bien entretenu et
bien organisés par les médias je cite
deux exemples france france culture
annonce une manifestation d'anti masque
à berlin avec des drapeaux du troisième
reich
on se dit quand même aïda corps le
lendemain antennes
j'allais dire antenne 2 je suis un peu
vieux france 2 france 2 parle d'une
manifestation de 16 mille manifestants
en petits masques et les seules images
qui montrent effectivement des drapeaux
nazis
d'un espace de petits groupes de
groupuscules de nazillons dans un coin
et heureusement il ya un petit un petit
pépé à la fin qui qui qui dit que ces
gens là sont vraiment pas nombreux mais
qui nous emmerdent mais que 99% de la
manif cdd zone et de père de famille
mais vous voyez comment les médias
réalise amalgame complot ce fait à égal
fachosphère cd tam qu'ils utilisent et
donc ça veut dire que si vous êtes si
vous questionnez l'usagé du masque par
exemple dans l'espace public est une
énorme aberration si vous questionnez
l'usagé du masque à l'école si vous
questionnez bref la politique vous êtes
immédiatement suspect de vous rapprocher
de l'extrême droite
et ça c'est un c'est un piège qui
paralyse la gauche depuis maintenant que
mitterrand a installé à l'extrême droite
comme système pour faire élire les
maquereaux etc etc
c'est à dire que ce qui est quand même
sidérant dans cette dans cette affaire
c'est le silence de la gauche
institutionnelle je sais pas où elle est
je suis dire elle est pas la fin juillet
je les entends pas faim j'ai envie de
dire à mes copains de la france
insoumise les mains quéau a soumettez
vous l'avez à l'isi je veux dire l'objet
est pas d'heure aujourd'hui de réclamer
la gratuité des masques c'est de
réclamer l'abolition des masques dans la
rue
d'accord moi quand je vois des petits
vieux qui conduisent avec leurs masques
enfin je veux dire qu'est ce qu'on a
réussi à nous faire faire un truc de fou
mais vous voyez comment le coup on nous
refile coude et gilet jaune
vous vous rappelez de saint leu les 86
première garde à vue aux champs elysées
le ministre prend la parole pour dire
que c'est l'ultra droite l'ultra-droite
merde
en fait on s'aperçoit que aucun de ces
gens n'étaient politisé surtout pas à
droite c'était tous des plombiers des
menuisiers c'était des gens qui
bossaient mais ça a suffi pour que la
gauche immédiatement face une
assimilation gilet jaune égale extrême
droite égale raciste égale fasciste et
on est en train de faire exactement la
même chose en ce moment et donc si vous
êtes de gauche vous allez forcément
devenir complotistes pour pas qu'on
puisse vous soupçonnez
d'être du côté de l'extrême droite et le
piège et parchet katia langues
vous étiez beaucoup élevé contre le
l'enseignement à distance pendant le
premier confinement il sauf que pendant
le 2ème confinement celui dont on est
censé sortir à la mi décembre
dix ans c'est parce que ça dépendra
encore des chiffres on a laissé ouvert à
obéir
on a on a laissé ouvert les écoles les
lycées
donc on vous a entendu de voix y être
contente
oui mais qu'on est ouvert au service de
la question de l'enseignement encore une
fois c'est pas forcément la caisse la
question c'était en éducation populaire
on essaie de voir les chevaux sur du
long terme aussi c'est pas moi je suis
pas habilité à dire réellement il
fallait rouvrir par ouvrir c'est
important encore une fois on va revenir
sur cette même question
la question c'est de d'analysé
d'observer ce qui est passé dans ce
conte à wimereux de manière pour le coup
assez violente bon jean et que peut-être
c'était nécessaire avec l'école à
distance est comment est-ce que ça
permet d'instituer d un champ nouveau
dans l'éducation de modifier
tranquillement mais sûrement et
profondément les pédagogies les
organisations travaillent et le rapport
même de l'enfant à l'école
voilà quel est ce que du sens de l'école
et si on le rattache à une analyse de
systèmes et bien on voit bien pour ceux
qui y concourent âge de lire un petit
peu les rapports de l' ocde
par exemple notamment et bien on sait
très bien que ça fait longtemps qu'ils
attendent ça de pouvoir ouvrir l'école
aux marchés éducatif ils sont poussés
par les gars femme derrière
et donc voilà c'est les gros buteur n'a
7 milliards de dollars
en france c'est le marché ducati
français 20 milliards en europe et donc
il ya nécessité à ouvrir ses marchés
l'an donc comment est-ce qu'on peut les
ouvrir et bien on a déjà mis en place un
certain nombre de choses hein on
appauvrit ont fait la même chose qu'avec
le système de santé publique on
appauvrit dans un premier temps c'est à
dire on fait des coupes budgétaires met
en place des procédures on met en place
la démarche qualité
et puis à partir de là on appauvrit les
métiers on appauvrit la possibilité pour
les travailleurs de penser leur métier
dans leur bus dans la globalité on crée
des dysfonctionnements et une fois que
ça dysfonctionne on sort l'innovation
c'est formidable et là l'innovation
c'est
et effectivement l'enseignement à
distance des mèdes 2020 la au mois de
mai il ya eu projet de loi qui est sorti
pour l'enseignement numérique distant
ciel projet de loi n'est qu'un projet de
loi on est d'accord mais quand même
c'est parti sur les lycées les collèges
et les écoles en france
les camarades européens observent la
même chose ça veut dire qu'ils sont ils
sont prêts quoi c'est ce qu'a d'ailleurs
on ne le dit blanc caire dès le début du
confinement il dit pour l'école à
distance nous sommes prêts alors ce à
quoi les enseignants répondre ah bon
parce que ils ont galéré
ils ont énormément travaillé pour
pouvoir essayer de mettre en place et de
maintenir un lien pédagogique quand même
et relationnel avec avec les enfants et
les ont battus qu'ils ont fait ça au
mieux de ce qu'il pouvait mais lui il
était prêt à ses formidables car ça veut
dire quoi nous on est prêts va ça veut
dire que le cned a déjà travaillé dessus
ça veut dire que ça veut dire que ils
sont prêts à passer à l'école à distance
est ce à ce que ça veut dire et ça c'est
pas complotistes se dire c'est écrit il
le devint 2019
je me sais plus comment ça s'appelle
voilà le lors d'un à ludovia en 2019 et
voilà les transformations pédagogique et
l'organisation profonde de l'école
passera par l'évolution fin se fera
grâce au numérique
donc ces annonces et je veux dire c'est
un projet que dans les boîtes et ce qui
est assez insupportable c'est que les
travailleurs à l'intérieur de ça les
enseignants et les soignants c'est le
même combat on est on est complètement
dans le même bateau on se retrouve
dépossédé de son travail on se retrouve
pris d'emblée dans des injonctions de
procédure la question de la relation
personnelle elle est mise à distance
alors il ya des médecins qui débarque
aussi en même temps tout ça c'est pas
anodin
sacyr quoi ça sert qui puisque ce ne
sont pas les travailleurs eux mêmes qui
le demandent
eh ben on peut se poser la question qui
ça sert évidemment nous après derrière
ben on va faire effectivement cette
analyse de systèmes et et l'accusé les
marchés financiers notamment et voilà
les détenteurs des guides et des
capitaux qu'ils ont besoin de continuer
à faire fructifier en dehors d'un
système de production qui lui arrive un
peu à un peu saturé à sion sans doute
mais on peut dire aussi que tout
simplement
pourquoi la santé pourquoi l'éducation
parce que ce sont deux postes
extrêmement lourd pour les états c'est
ce qui coûte le plus cher
la police aujourd'hui on voit dans la
loi de sécurité globale pour qu'on ouvre
là à la à la police municipale
c'est une façon la police municipale ça
coûte moins cher que la police nationale
donc on s'y retrouve c'est moins lourd
dans le budget comme dans l'armée
ben l'armée américaine par exemple a
déjà externalisé un certain nombre de
compétences auprès auprès de mercenaires
ou des agences plus ou moins privé parce
que ça coûte moins cher de la même façon
c'est peut-être tout simplement ça ça
coûte moins cher c'est pour être la
seule raison et une captation des
calculs va se faire différemment
vas-y francky tech days from local la
question c'est que ça coûte moins cher à
qui je veux dire qu'est-ce qui est
comment comment et financer le système
de santé le système hospitalier français
il est financé par des cotisations sont
les employeurs qui paye venir c'est ce
système marche marche est
remarquablement bien d'accord la france
était le sixième pays plus riches du
monde c'est un capitalisme florissant
tout va bien avec de très très beaux
services publics puisque tout le monde
nous enviait notre système hospitalier
d'accord le problème c'est que à partir
du moment vous baisser les recettes
c'est à dire où vous autoriser les
entreprises
vous allez vous les exonérer des
fameuses charges sociales c'est très
simple sur une fiche de paye vous avez
une maladie mais si vous enlevez cette
ligne il faut virer une infirmière ou un
médecin quelque part c'est aussi bête
que ça
donc le il faut arrêter de dire que ça
coûte fin cela ça coûte pas ça coûte si
vous êtes si vous supprimez les recettes
mais te dire depuis quand enfin depuis
quand est ce qu'on trouve normal
d'exonérer les entreprises de leurs de
l'heure de leur obligation de participer
au bien commun vient la question
la question est là aussi philippe
veulent intervenir
ce qu'on dit notamment sur le passage au
numérique et du coup la transformation
en marche et privatisé de secteurs comme
la santé éducation etc
c'est que d'abord c'était effectivement
dans les tiroirs depuis très longtemps
et c'est pour ça qu'on a des réactions
aussi rapide
voilà épique à aucun débat démocratique
là dessus c'est à dire que par exemple
je vois là il y avait un colloque était
organisé sur comment le numérique va
améliorer les services publics sur les
territoires c'est à dire que on passe à
la question du comment sans avoir posé
la question de s que voilà est ce que
c'est un choix possibles imaginables
non en fait toute la machine est déjà en
route pour le passage au numérique aux
distances yale dans à peu près tous les
domaines de l'activité y compris
l'activité publique et maintenant on
discute juste du comment voilà et par
ailleurs ce passage au numérique ça
s'accompagne effectivement de la
privatisation large parce que les
prestataires de services moi j'ai été
atteint du coït pas très gravement
et bien tout de suite j'ai eu plein de
propositions qui m'arrivait par mail et
par sms de me brancher sur une
plateforme de suivi mme numérique voilà
qu était détenu par un prestataire privé
qui vous avertissent et en même temps si
vous aviez un truc grave il fallait
absolument
contactez votre médecin généraliste ou
appeler le 15 mai par ailleurs fin voilà
donc ça ouvre bien des marchés à des
prestataires ça s'accompagne
complètement en fait le passage au
numérique et le fait d'ouvrir des
marchés à des prestataires privés dont
on peut se demander à quoi ils savent où
quelquefois et sans qu'elle sache il
faut passer la parole à katia parce que
c'est présenté comme une innovation
pédagogique c'est à dire que on vous dit
ça va ça va ça va améliorer l'éducation
ça va faire plus d'égalité ça va être
serré et toutes les études montrent
exactement le contraire si tu veux en
dire un mot quatre 4 oui bah on imagine
que donc voilà si on si on imagine que
ok on va passer au maintien l'école à
distance on va on va continuer les
expérimentations qui sont là on peut
déjà observer ce qu'il ya plusieurs
l enquête qui doit par exemple évalue
les résultats et les niveaux on va dire
scolaire niveau européen il montre que
tous les pays qui obtiennent les
meilleurs résultats sont ceux où il ya
le moins l'informatique à l'école et où
il ya le moins de temps en informatique
à la maison pour les enfants
voilà ça c'était déjà c'est déjà une
première chose tout les tout ce qui a
été fait depuis déjà quelques années
parce qu il existe déjà la formation à
distance 1 on a testé les mots quand on
a testé différentes choses on est à 30 à
50 % d'abandons
par exemple là dessus donc ça veut dire
que tu as des as poneys sa déscolarisent
un certain nombre de personnes
il ya plein de travaux qui sont faits
sur les besoins affectifs qui soit un
préalable nécessaire qui crée la
motivation c'est la relation qui crée la
motivation et c'est parce que il ya
motivation que je peux rentrer en phase
d'apprentissage donc si on enlève cet
élément là ça ne fonctionne plus en fait
ils ne peuvent pas justifier on ne peut
pas justifier que l'enseignement à
distance va rendre les enfants plus
performant il a acquis toutes les études
montrent linverse dans ce qui a déjà été
fait donc on est obligé de se poser la
question c'est pas dans l'intérêt bien
on va faire ça une encore moins
évidemment dans ceux des enseignants et
des parents
parce que pour le coup et donc on peut
l'analyser
à nous de par exemple de la domination
patriarcale aussi qu'est ce que c'est un
moment l'enseignement à distance dans
une dans une société patriarcale ses
intérêts sans pouvoir questionner ça ça
veut dire que si je suis plus toute la
journée en mixité garçon fille si je me
confronte plus à la réalité de l'autre
au corps de l'autre
comment est ce que je te m'émanciper de
mes conditions matérielles
je suis un gars de ton qui comme à peu
près tous les garçons de france voir ma
mère faire 1h30 de ménages de plus de
tâches domestiques de plus que mon père
comment est ce que je peux voilà mes
exemptés ou m'émanciper de cette
éducation complètement genre et à
distance
donc pour moi l'école à distance en tout
cas les conséquences je n'ai pas qu'ils
font pour que ça je dis qu'ils les
conséquences de ça ça va être encore un
accroissement des demies
a sion sur les pubs voilà sur les plus
fragiles et puis évidemment et puis
évidemment pas pour les classes
populaires pour les personnes qui
n'auront pas le capital économique ou
capitale culturelle pour pouvoir
accompagner leurs enfants
ça c'est des conséquences dramatiques et
c'est ce contre quoi on doit se battre
et peu m'importe le coup je ne suis pas
d'accord pour qu'on raisonne sur
l'éducation et sur la santé en termes de
coûts on doit raisonner en termes de
projet de société qu'est ce qu'on veut
qu'est ce qu'on veut et les gens sont en
capacité de se rencontrer se voir
d'échangé c'est ce qu'on croit nous dans
l'éducation populaire et de pouvoir le
penser par eux-mêmes dernière session
annuelle qui te il nous reste six
minutes
emmanuel macron hier dans son discours a
dit que le vaccin quand il arrivera ne
sera pas obligatoire
certains ont été surpris il faut dire
que ce serait bien la première fois
qu'un vaccin serait obligatoire pour les
adultes dans l'histoire de l'humanité
ça ne s'est jamais vu les vaccins
obligatoires ne l'ont jamais été que
pour les enfants et à chaque fois ça a
créé des mouvements anti vaccins déjà au
19e siècle avait des mouvements anti
vaccin dès l'instant où vous voulez
rendre obligatoire par exemple pour les
enfants le vaccin contre la variole
néanmoins il l'a dit le vaccin ne sera
pas obligatoire
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
au collectif l'ardeur franck lepage
blague c'est une blague
enfin je veux dire d'abord le fait
qu'ils disent j'ai décidé que ce serait
pas obligatoire
je veux dire ça veut dire qu'il décidera
que ça serait que ça deviendra
obligatoire le jo ça le chantera en
réalité ce qui est intéressant c'est ce
qu'a dit la haute autorité de santé
en gros la haute autorité de santé dit
dans un premier temps on va faire la
pédagogie
il aime beaucoup la pédagogie mais s'il
n'y a pas 75 % de la population qui est
vacciné il faudra passer à des mesures
plus coercitives
donc ça c'est une recommandation
d'accord donc je pense que macron est
pour l'instant dans cette phrase de dire
on va tellement continuer à angoisser
les gens avec des chiffres complètement
aberrant que on va probablement
atteindre les 75 % de vaccination ne
sera pas la peine de le rendre
obligatoire le problème c'est que pour
l'instant on n'est qu'à 50 9% je crois
de français qui sont prêts à se faire
vacciner c'est pas suffisant pour eux
donc ok le vaccin sera pas obligatoire
pour l'instant je vois pas comment
macron pourrait résister à la puissance
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques ça
m'étonnerait quand vous avez vu ce qui
s'est passé les bourses qui explosent à
partir de voir une annonce qu'il ya un
vaccin qui est prêt le pdg qui vend ses
actions qui fait 5 millions d'euros le
lendemain de l'annoncé jeudi un bond est
ce que ma coin la possibilité de
résister à ça comme un conte reçoit
blackrock larry fink à l'elysée qui
représente hicks fois le pib de la
france je dis est ce que vous pensez que
que macro à la passivité de résister à
blackrock pour vendre les retraites à
blackrock une pensée qui peut faire ça
veut dire on est au delà la gouvernance
c'est l'impuissance du gouvernement
c'est le pouvoir des multinationales
c'est ça qu'on veut c'est ça qu'on va
voir et dans le cadre de l'éducation va
envoyer avoir droit je reprends les
chiffres que quelques qu'at-il à donner
trop hâtivement c'est 7000 milliards
d'euros c'est le marché éducatif
européen
selon les estimations de la cds et 20
mille milliards d'euros c'est le marché
éducatif mondial et ce qui est très
intéressant
ils veulent tous aller sur cette
concurrence c'est à dire que le ministre
français
si tu les start up française de
l'éducation à y aller pour conquérir les
marchés des autres pays c'est à dire
qu'on est dans cette folie de
concurrence de mise en place d'un marché
et les profs vont rester sur la touche
les profs ne seront plus des enseignants
regardez la relation pédagogique elle va
sauter les profs seront simplement des
gens qui vont faire fonctionner des
logiciels et c'est le logiciel qui
déterminera la progression dans la
matière c'est pas les enseignants ces
logiciels seront payants fera des
abonnements chemin bref on y va tout
droit
c'est pour ça que faudrait qu'on arrête
un petit peu de s'énerver sur l'île roxy
chloroquine et comme commence à prendre
un peu de recul vous regardez ce qui se
passe avec cette histoire de coheed et
là la gauche je suis désolée la gauche
et par là je ne sais pas où il est mais
elle est pas là c'est encore les gilet
jaune qui vont devoir se taper le boulot
fait vers l'an dernier mot non rien
rajouter à ce qu'a dit franck sur
l'analyse sur le vaccin
vientiane dernier mot je vais pas rendre
avec deux minutes d'avancé se serait
jamais arrivé quelque chose je veux bien
rajouter quelque chose à propos de
l'éducation populaire et moi j'essaye de
faire un peu d'éducation populaire au
media et sur cette histoire de que les
gens seraient pas conscience l'imbécile
etc
tiens je veux bien qu'on montre une une
de marianne non pardon excusez moi c'est
pas la une de marianne c'est la une de
l'express pour une réforme brutale du
travail à une de l'ex à vous laver alors
ça c'est pas c'était marianne voilà
c'est celle ci l'express que vous nous
avez envoyé voilà pour une réforme
radicale du travail c'était au moment de
la loi travail et donc ils interviewent
quatre experts pour leur demander leurs
points de vue une fois je suis dans une
classe de 5e d'un collège zep zep je
remonte cette une
et il y en a un qui me dit immédiatement
ben oui ces quatre hommes 4 blanc et
quatre avec cravate
voilà il l'avait vu tout de suite et
c'est normal c'est à dire que les
dominer il voit bien quand ils sont pas
là en fait alors que les dominants
général ben il voit même pas que ça
représente ce qu'ils sont c'est à dire
des gens comme moi blanc bourgeois mal
voilà mais eux ils le voient enfin voilà
donc je pense qu'il ya cette
intelligence du côté des dominés de
percevoir absolument les systèmes de
domination et qui passe notamment par
les médias donc nous ont misé là dessus
quand on fait de l'éducation populaire
et puis ça tu es parler du travail en
estime à une augmentation de
productivité de 20 à 22% le fait de
travailler à la maison c'est à dire de
continuer à bosser jusqu'à 21h d'en
faire encore plus d'être encore plus
surveillés donc tout ça cette magnifique
révolution numérique avec les gars
charme
on le doit à un tout petit virus qui
chez quand même pas tout le monde ment
en gardant bien ce sera le mot de la fin
de franck lepage vous remercie tous les
trois d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]